[la musique]
très dur très dur où nous avons 17 ans
c'était le cas, mais j'étais capable de porter un tel Texas
à cette époque nous étions torturés par des fascistes
les avions seulement tellement et
travaillé parce que nous avons travaillé sur le fond
et je n'avais nulle part où aller, j'étais seul
seulement
Le frère de Sarny a envoyé des triangles par
J'ai tout lu et d'un coup je fais des triangles
s'est enfui au front, il est mort, je reste
une
Je vais à mes équipes Sokolsky draft office
et passé
renvoyez-moi et les vices du linge sur le frod
Nous n'avons vu ni le début ni la fin
Au début ou à la fin, nous suffoquions à cause de ça
travailler
village, tous frapper les nazis n'étaient rien
il n'y avait absolument rien d'autre que j'ai pris
Je ne pouvais même pas voir ma grand-mère
rencontre de la tromperie de nous très
super rencontre bébé cousu
fais-toi vivre
alors ce n'est pas d'être dans ce
Je veux vraiment que tu écrives dehors
lettre je serai très satisfait et heureux
[la musique]